REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Ver el recurso de App interpuesto por el representante del Ministerio público
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: dentro del proceso penal que sigue el Ministerio público contra Guillermo Alexander, montañosa por el presunto delito de pornografía con carácter previo a la señora Secretaria, infórme si los sujetos procesales han sido debidamente notificados y quienes se encuentran presentes en la audiencia.
secretaria: Se informa a su autoridad que para la audiencia.
secretaria: Ingeniero. Por favor, la calidad del conflicto no va a disculpar envío de Internet. Esta pésima de teléfono se informa a su autoridad, que representa audiencia de apelación, que ha sido interpuesta
secretaria: el ministerio público únicamente por el ministerio público. Los sujetos procesales que fueron notificados por esta audiencia estando presente en sala. La parte civil. La señora María Sandra Castero desistió de su abogado, el doctor Fernando Santos
secretaria: también se encuentra la parte de imputada. Señor Guillermo Montaño, quien se encuentra asistido de su abogado o abogada, perdón. Laura y lonca
secretaria: Con respecto a la asistencia del Ministerio Público.
secretaria: se ha identificado al fiscal titular de la causa. El doctor Daniel Fernando Lobo, sin embargo, de la revisión del Acta. La apelación ha sido interpuesta por el doctor Mijael cavero, el mismo que ha manifestado que el fiscal titular de la causa sería el doctor Daniel Fernando Lobo.
secretaria: Es todo en contra, lo que forma nuestra autoridad y haciendo conocer que está dando inicio a la audiencia, ahora 14 y 0. Cuatro de la tarde, toda vez que nos encontrábamos también en una audiencia de apelación de manera virtual.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: La palabra, Señor, su autoridad, señora Juez.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Tiene presente el informe de la señora Secretaria y
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: toda vez de que ha solicitado la palabra, la doctora franco no sí doctora. Tiene la palabra.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Muchas gracias a su autoridad con carácter previo a su propia autoridad. Queremos poner en conocimiento de que la audiencia de apelación incidental interpuesta por parte del Ministerio público. Ya se ha llevado a cabo en la sala penal segunda
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: para fecha 5 de septiembre, 5 de noviembre del 2 025, la misma que ya ha sido resuelta
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: y ha sido declarada
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: inadmisible el recurso, Por supuesto que el ministerio público no se hizo presente y no se encontraron presentes los agravios, entonces por parte de del apelante. En este caso, el ministerio público
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: hacer conocer también a su autoridad que la parte civil no es no es apelante y no ha hecho uso de su derecho de apelación ni de manera oral. En la En la misma audiencia
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: de medidas de cesación que se llevó que fue una audiencia de verificación de cumplimiento del plazo conforme lo que establecía la resolución que sacó el Tribunal Departamental de Justicia, pero aún así ha tenido el plazo correspondiente
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: de que la ley marca para haberlo planteado de manera escrita, hecho que tampoco ha ocurrido Entonces, De esta misma forma la Sala Penal. Segunda, ha resuelto declararlo inadmisible y confirma en su totalidad el auto interlocutorio. 492 95, y por de esa forma, es que le solicitamos a su prueba autoridad
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: pueda
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: declarar nula esta esta convocatoria, esta audiencia de apelación, porque la misma ya ha sido resuelta, como has dicho anteriormente. Conforme al artículo 404, y también conforme al artículo 16 numeral, 2 del órgano judicial, donde se establece el principio de preclusión
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: y lo mismo que establece conforme al artículo 17 de la misma normativa penal, ya que esto protegen el debido proceso, la seguridad jurídica, la prohibición de la doble del doble enjugamiento procesal y que proscribe la la duplicidad de actos jurisdiccionales a su prueba autoridad. Le solicitamos.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Doctora.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Se respeten los derechos y garantías de el imputado y, por favor, pueda dejar sin efecto la presente audiencia la misma que ya no tendría su propia autoridad, competencia para llevar adelante. Muchísimas gracias.
mijail cavero: La palabra. Señor señor Presidente.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Un segundito. Por favor.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: tiene la palabra el representante del Ministerio público.
mijail cavero: Su prioridad un saludo atento a su persona y a todos los presentes su probidad.
mijail cavero: Habían escuchado muy atentamente lo manifestado por su señora Secretaria.
mijail cavero: hago mención lo siguiente: su propio defecto de no caer en errores también, y por el principio de objetividad que el ministerio público ejerce
mijail cavero: efectivamente si mi persona ha planteado en su momento una apelación, Pero esto fue en suplencia legal del fiscal titular hago conocer a las autoridades que el suscriptor fiscal no es titular de la investigación. No tengo en este momento la
mijail cavero: las pelas, pero no tengo los actuados ni el cuaderno de investigación. Y todavía que en este momento, hace 2 min o 3 me han notificado con el link.
mijail cavero: Yo quiero hacer consenso a su autoridad, considere, y también no se vulnere ningún derecho, también de las partes y, si fuese necesario su propiedad, este solicitar la suspensión de esta presunta audiencia si fuese el caso, y notificar al fiscal titular a efecto de que él mismo pueda defender
mijail cavero: esta apelación. Muchas gracias.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Se tiene presente ambas intervenciones y efectos de aclarar la incidencia planteada por la doctora, lauda y lonca franco Crespo
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: se le pide a la señora Secretaria que informe al respecto.
secretaria: Complementando el informe. Señor Presidente, de la revisión de actuados procesales, que ha sido remitido a este tribunal de arzada conforme al oficio
secretaria: emitido por la Tolvania Caballero, Saavedra, oficio número 2: 1 973 del 11 de septiembre con cargo de recepción por parte de la subasta secretaria. El 12 de septiembre a 8 y media de la mañana en fotocopia legalizada refiere el oficio que ha sido remitido a esta sala para que se reserva la apelación
secretaria: en contra de la resolución. Número 492 de fecha. Cinco de septiembre del 2 025 en cuya foja 10 del Acta de audiencia a
secretaria: concursantes, fojas. 119 vuelta el Ministerio público Representante, el abogado Mijail Cavero Zurita, manifiesta
secretaria: y lo siguiente: 1, la verdad hace conocer que el suscrito fiscal está en suplencia legal y ha sido llamado por la autoridad fiscal que consta en alta que suscrito. No es que no haya fundamentado como manifiesta Usted me ha cortado la palabra. Yo no podía decir nada más. De todas maneras, el suscrito fiscal va a hacer uso del recurso de apelación
secretaria: consta en alta la interposición de recurso de apelación por parte del ministerio público. Señor Presidente.
secretaria: ese es el oficio. La resolución que ha sido arremetida este Tribunal del S A. D. A esto de encuentro Tengo que complementar el
secretaria: el informe desconociendo la remisión a la sala penal? Segunda: ¿Qué tipo de resolución sería, señor Presidente?
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Doctora franco han sido remitidas 2 apelaciones de manera paralela.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Muchas gracias. Su autoridad no, no, no existe.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Hola, Sí, me escucha o la.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Bueno.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Me escuchas.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Sí. Ahora, sí, doctora.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Muchas gracias. Autoridad. No, no existen 2 apelaciones. Si bien existe una una devolución del expediente al juzgado por el tema cuando ya el Ministerio Público plantea una acusación, pero esta devolución del tribunal de sentencia tiene del tribunal de sentencia, tiene que ver con un tema de unificación del proceso, porque el ministerio público, después de haber planteado
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: acusación en contra del imputado Guillermo Alexander montañosa Beadra
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: presenta imputación contra otra persona, entonces vía saneamiento. El tribunal de sentencia devuelve el expediente al juzgado a quo. No desconozco si, por la otra parte, tienen algún incidente que resolver, Pero en contra del ciudadano Guillermo Alexander, Montaño Saavedra, no existe otro incidente en su contra y el mismo. Como le pongo en conocimiento, ha sido ya resuelto y hemos sido notificados.
secretaria: Doctora doctora disculpe. Ha manifestado usted que la apelación fue resuelta por la sala penal. Segunda: usted cuenta con esa documentación me la puede mandar. Por favor una fotografía. Lo escribo en el chat y número de teléfono.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Sí, por favor, Sí, sí. No puedo mandar.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Palabra. Señor Presidente.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Un minuto. Doctor.
secretaria: Doctora. Por favor, la estoy esperando una foto, aunque sea a menudo teléfono. Por favor.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: No me ha llegado nada. Por eso de que no
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: puedo subirle, No, me no me ha llegado.
secretaria: Esto es.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: En el.
secretaria: Sí.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Ohh.
secretaria: Plataforma en.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Y ya está lo subo enseguida. Por favor. Un minuto. Por
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: ya se lo he remitido doctora, por favor.
secretaria: Lo verifiquen.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Previamente a resolver la incidencia planteada. Tiene la palabra la defensa técnica de la parte civil, quien habría solicitado la misma hace unos instantes.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Muchas gracias, señor Presidente. Con su venia.
Abg. Fernando Santos: señor Presidente, 1 de los principios básicos por los cuales debe regirse el ejercicio de la abogacía
Abg. Fernando Santos: es el de lealtad procesal. En ese sentido, pongo conocimiento de vuestra autoridad
Abg. Fernando Santos: que en el presente proceso penal.
Abg. Fernando Santos: en el cual está imputado el señor Guillermo Alexander, Montaño Saavedra, por el delito de pornografía.
Abg. Fernando Santos: existían 2 apelaciones incidentales: La primera apelación incidental Señor Presidente data del 7 de agosto del presente año
Abg. Fernando Santos: existía una segunda apelación incidental que tenía la fecha de 5 de septiembre del presente año
Abg. Fernando Santos: es precisamente el auto interlocutorio. Número 492 025 del 5 de septiembre, Mhm.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Teniendo en cuenta, señor Presidente, que si tiene una dilación indebida, Un procesamiento indebido por parte de la juez Albania, caballero juez de introducción cautelar penal, anticorrupción número 16 de la capital
Abg. Fernando Santos: es que, en aras de que esta autoridad jurisdiccional pueda
Abg. Fernando Santos: ejercer lo que por ley corresponde en fecha 29. De septiembre, Señor Presidente.
Abg. Fernando Santos: pusimos una denuncia, interpusimos en contra de la jueza antes mencionada. La jueza q
Abg. Fernando Santos: una denuncia disciplinaria. De la misma forma, en fecha. 29 de septiembre interpusimos una recusación en contra de la jueza
Abg. Fernando Santos: y el 12 de septiembre. Señor Presidente, interpusimos una acción de libertad toda vez de que la la perdón, el 29 de septiembre.
Abg. Fernando Santos: el 12 de septiembre interpusimos una una acción de libertad en contra de la juez Albania, caballero
Abg. Fernando Santos: toda vez que no remitía precisamente estos 2 recursos. La apelación del 7 de agosto y la apelación del 5 de septiembre.
Abg. Fernando Santos: el tribunal de garantía.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Contra el otro.
Abg. Fernando Santos: El Tribunal de garantías. Señor Presidente.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: No, claro.
Abg. Fernando Santos: A cargo de él
Abg. Fernando Santos: del tribunal de ese, el tribunal de sentencia penal anticorrupción y violencia contra la muerte. Séptimo de la capital.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Mhm.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Constituido.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Las incidencias están por demás.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Sí
Abg. Fernando Santos: ya voy a terminar de manera puntual que el tribunal de sentencia penal anticorrupción y violencia contra la mujer. Séptimo, la capital constituido en tribunal de garantía
Abg. Fernando Santos: exhorta en la parte dipositiva de la sentencia a la juez Albania, caballero en que remita las 2 apelaciones, la del 7 de agosto y la del 5 de septiembre del presente año.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Nótese, señor Presidente, que la jueza Albania, caballero autoridad jurisdiccional que asumí el control jurisdiccional del presente proceso
Abg. Fernando Santos: a través de 2 oficios distintos, que remite la misma apelación en un acto doloso con la única finalidad de perjudicar la apelación interpuesta por mi patrocinada, que precisamente es la del 7 de agosto, únicamente remite la apelación incidental del 5 de septiembre
Abg. Fernando Santos: a 2 diferentes salas, generando en su despacho en su sala en su sala penal, su
Abg. Fernando Santos: asignaron el número de expedientes, 618 barrios, 1 025, y en la sala
Abg. Fernando Santos: penal segunda a cargo del vocal Freddy Larrea, se designó el expediente, 818 2 025,
Abg. Fernando Santos: Pero estas 2,
Abg. Fernando Santos: estos 2 expedientes, señor Presidente, tienen como único objeto y finalidad resolver la apelación únicamente la del 5 de septiembre del presente año, Es decir, en síntesis, la jueza Q ha remitido toda la misma apelación
Abg. Fernando Santos: a 2 salas distintas, generando que sus autoridades puedan emitir duplicidad de resoluciones, obviamente vulnerando la seguridad jurídica y prácticamente poner en un caos total no en la administración de justicia.
Abg. Fernando Santos: Esos actos, Señor Presidente, para que su propiedad lo tome en cuenta
Abg. Fernando Santos: ha sido por parte del accionar de la juez de Albania caballero que el día de hoy, reitero, está siendo procesada en la vía disciplinaria. Eso es todo, señor Presidente, estas actuaciones. Pongo en conocimiento. Reitero, en base al principio de lealtad procesal, ya para que vuestra Autoridad determine lo que por ley corresponde.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Se tiene presente lo manifestado por el abogado
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: y tam del la parte civil, así también lo manifestado por la abogada de la defensa técnica del imputado y es necesario precisar 2 aspectos.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: El principal aspecto que la solicitud que hace el representante del ministerio público en relación
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: que no sería él el titular de la causa y pide que se notifique al titular, toda vez que él únicamente habría actuado en esa oportunidad en suplencia legal.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Y el segundo aspecto es el siguiente.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: que acusa a la parte es imputada, que existen 2 apelaciones que ya han sido remitidas distintas salas y ya habrían sido resueltos por su parte. La parte civil
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: ha aclarado dicho aspecto y ha señalado que el jugador origen habría creado una
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: una especie de incongruencia o confusión en relación a remitir las apelaciones. De ahí que.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: en principio es necesario diferir la presente audiencia por 2 aspectos, en principio, porque el fiscal debe notificarse al fiscal titulado de la causa y, en segundo lugar, porque se ha expuesto
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: un elemento sumamente importante, que es la duplicidad de resoluciones y tomando en cuenta de que en este cuaderno procesal no se tiene antecedentes, sino lo que ha remitido la
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: abogada. Sin embargo, no son documentos que puedan valorarse en este momento.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: por lo que se va a diferir la audiencia
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: y se ordenara la sala penal.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Segunda, remita copia legalizada del oficio de remisión del juzgado, así como también la resolución emitida.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: a las cuales han referido las partes
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: en el plazo de 24 h de notificado lo mismo con el oficio correspondiente
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: fecha en la y se señala audiencia para el día
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: viernes 21, de noviembre, a las vein de 2 025 a las 8 y cuarto, perdón, 8 y 4 min de manera virtual.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: a efecto de llevar a cabo la audiencia en la cual, una vez
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: obtenida dicha documentación, se resolverá la incidencia planteada por ambas partes y, en su defecto, se dispondrá si da corresponde dar continuidad al desarrollo de manera integral o inicialmente, hay que resolver la incidencia
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: quedando los sujetos procesales en este momento notificados en la audiencia.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: notifíquese a la parte ausente conforme a ley y resuelto.
REYNALDO SÁNCHEZ FLORES: Lo he explicado, se da por concluida la misma. Tengan ustedes muy buenas tardes.
LAURA ILONKA FRANCO CRESPO: Muchas gracias, señor Juez.